بينما تتواصلُ الحربُ الدائرةُ في سوريا تتشكل خيوطُ توافقٍ روسيٍ فرنسي بشأن آلية التنسيقِ في ضرب الإرهاب.
ثُلاثيةٌ مفاجئة ألقاها وزير الخارجية الفرنسي لوران فابيوس في ثنايا الحرب على داعش.
الجيشُ السوري الحر وقواتٌ كردية والجيشُ السوري ضمن تصورٍ لهيكلية قوات برية تقاتلُ التنظيمَ الإرهابيَ على الأرض
رغم أن فابيوس عاد لاحقاً وأكد أن مشاركةَ الجيش السوري لا يمكن طرحُها إلا في إطار الانتقالِ السياسي حصراً وفق تعبيره.
كما أضاف الوزيرُ الفرنسي أنه في حالة البدء في التحرك لا يمكن للرئيس السوري بشار الأسد أن يقود ذلك مضيفاً أن الأسد لا يمكن أن يمثل مستقبلَ الشعب السوري.
تصريحاتُ فابيوس تأتي عقبَ جملةِ تفاهماتٍ وردت في لقاء الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين بنظيره الفرنسي فرانسوا هولاند إذ أعلنَ الجانبــانِ  أنهما اتفقا على الآتي:
-- تنسيقُ الضرباتِ الجوية في سوريا
- تكثيفُ الضربات ضد تنظيمِ داعش والاستهداف المحددُ لوسائل نقلِ المنتجات النفطية
- تبادلُ المعلومات الاستخبارية حول داعش والتنظيماتِ الأخرى: وفي هذه النقطة أشارت باريسُ إلى أن موسكو طلبت وضع خريطةٍ للمواقعِ التي تنشط فيها المجموعاتُ غيرُ الارهابية التي تقاتل  تنظيمِ داعش في سوريا حتى لا تستهدِفَها في غاراتِها.
هذا التقاربُ الفرنسيُ الروسي لم يمنع المتحدثَ باسم الرئاسةِ الروسية ديمتري بيسكوف من إعلان أن الدُول الغربيةَ غيرُ مستعدة للعملِ مع روسيا في ائتلاف موحدٍ لمحاربة داعش، لكنه أشار في الوقت نفسِه إلى أن موسكو ستبقي الباب مفتوحاً أمام شركائِها في هذا المجال.
معطياتٌ جديدة برزت على صعيدِ الحرب على الإرهاب ... لكنَ أيَ تأويلٍ لمحددات الربحِ والخسارة في المواجهة مع داعش ستقاسُ على الأرجح بموازينِ تأثيرها على الأرض.